hi i'm drew and i'm tanks and we're  gonna play smashed your past smashed  smash ah past i would smash for the  story  smashed smash my virgo queen oh he's  married but like i love him yeah it's a  friendly smash respectful pass um  smashed smashed a hundred percent i mean  he's so funny i love it  yeah  let's agree to smash yeah join the party  uh come on everybody's everybody's doing  it all right  oh my goodness um what a lovely person i  will say again respectful pass for his  marriage respectful mass uh respectful  past  he's a friend so i think pads  oh smashed a whole thing smash i mean  everybody smashes 100 universal smash  yes i mean smashed on just like respect  and girl power yes same i smash it all  day long smash it with lactate yes